The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right
so today, we're
going to have a review of the
visual and oculomotor systems
that I've covered so far.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go over many, many
basic facts in a rather
quick fashion, which will sort
of refresh your memory of what
we have covered so far
and also will make you
more aware of what you want to
look at carefully when you look
at the material on the
website, on Stellar,
and also when you read
the assigned readings.
I want to remind all
of you again that you
will have to put
together that paper
on the accessory optic system
that I will mention very
briefly at the
end of the review.
And your prime task
there will be--
that's an old paper
published in the 1960s, which
was a major discovery
at the time--
and your task will
be predominantly
to say what-- well, first of all
what has been discovered there,
that you can cover in a
paragraph and then to add to it
what people have
contributed to the study
of that area since
that original paper.
All right, so anyway
then I will mention
at the end or so a bit
more about the exam, which
is going to take place on
Wednesday right in here, which
is going to consist of
multiple choice questions.
All right, so to
begin with then,
let's talk about the basic
wiring of the visual system
that we have covered.
And that is outlined here for
the primate and for the human.
And I should mention as I had
gone in the initial lecture
that this is different from
many of the lower level
species in which the
two eyes look sideways,
and each eye sends all of its
retinal ganglion cell axons
across to the other
hemisphere in the brain.
Now this big change
occurred when
the eyes move to the front.
And we have discussed already
why that may have happened.
And as a result of this, if you
imagine cutting your vertically
in half, you divide it into
the nasal and temporal hemi
retinae.
And it so happens
that the nasal hemi
retina of one eye and
the temporal retina
of the other eye
goes to one side,
and the obvious happens
to the other side.
The connections are made to
several areas, most notably
for our purposes, was the
lateral geniculate nucleus
but also the superior colliculus
and several other structures
that we have talked
about that include
the accessory optic system.
Once the connections
come up to the cortex,
several cortical areas-- we'll
talk about that in a minute--
have evolved that are involved
in progressively higher levels
of visual analysis.
Now this circle here--
hopefully you guys
remember-- is either called
the Vieth-Muller circle,
or it's called the horopter.
And it was shown by a
clever experimentalist
that if you put any
spot along that circle
when the person fixes at
this point in the circle,
all of those points impinge on
corresponding points in the two
retinae.
However, if there's
an object that
seemed to be beyond or closer
to the eye than the circle,
then they hit non equivalent
points in the retina.
And that non equivalency
is actually used
for depth perception,
as we have discussed,
and I will mention again when
it comes to a stereopsis.
So that is the very, very
basic wiring arrangement.
And then if you
proceed from here
and look at the retina and
the lateral geniculate nucleus
in a bit more detail, first
starting with the retina.
I wanted to point out
to you first of all
that there are two different
kinds of photoreceptors.
You all know this
very well by now.
You knew this before
you came to class.
You have the rods and the cones.
There are three basic types of
cones, red, green, and blue,
which more appropriately refer
to short, medium, and long
wavelength selective cones.
And then we have the rods.
Now what happens is
that the light comes in,
in this case from the bottom
if you look at yourself.
The light comes in, and
it goes through many
of the cells in the retina.
And it impinges
on the receptors,
which are facing away from
the light against the pigment
epithelium.
And as I've mentioned
to you, there
have been some
interesting questions
as to why this strange
arrangement had emerged.
Nobody had predicted that
before we had any anatomy,
people just thought if
there were any receptors,
they would face the light.
So that's certainly a strange
arrangement, an unusual one.
And a lot of
speculation have been
advanced as to why
this has happened.
And I will just briefly
mention two of those.
One is that when
these photoreceptors
are right against the
pigment epithelium, which
in diurnal animals is black,
and absorbs the photons thereby
preventing scattering of light.
As a result of which,
you can gain high acuity.
And that is known by the
fact that if you assess
the visual capacities of albinos
who don't have a black pigment
epithelium because they
lack pigment-- that's
the definition of
being an albino--
most people have very poor
vision because the photons
come into the eye, and they
scatter all over the place
and activate many photoreceptors
rather than just those
which the incoming photon
would hit directly.
So that is the
arrangement for these.
Another factor, which I don't
think I may not have mentioned
is that what you have
in these photoreceptors
are little packets, if you talk
about the rods in particular,
you have little
packets, each of which
has the molecules,
which are sensitive
to the incoming light.
And each of these
packets-- there
are about 1,000 packets
in each of these rods.
And each of those 1,000 packets
is about 10,000 molecules.
So we're talking about
gigantic numbers.
Now what happens is that given
this 1,000 of-- about 1,000
packets, they are not
there for your life.
What happens is that
the packets gradually
disintegrate and get
replaced by a new one.
It's about once every 10
days you lose a packet,
and you gain a new one.
Now that means that some of
this stuff gets sloughed off.
And one of the reasons people
think that the photoreceptors
ended up facing away from
the light is that they could
be close to this inner
part of the retina
where anything that's
sloughed off can be absorbed
rather than being just
thrown into the eye itself,
into the vitreous,
because if that
were to happen over
many, many years,
the vitreous would become
cloudy, and you couldn't see.
So those are two
possible reasons
why this strange
arrangement has evolved.
And you see this in
virtually all species.
There are just a few species
that have-- and most of those
are actually in the sea--
who have photoreceptors
that face towards the light.
All right, and then
if you proceed here,
the other amazing thing
that had been discovered
is that all the photoreceptors
hyper polarized to light.
Again, they do the opposite
of what people had thought.
You'd think that
when photons come in,
they would activate
the photoreceptors,
and they would send the
signal down the stream
through the eye.
Turns out the opposite
happens that the discharge
on the neurotransmitter
here occurs
when there's a darkening rather
than an increase in light.
That's an important
factor to remember.
That's true for all
the forests accept
as all photoreceptors
hyperpolarized to light.
You know this well already.
I must have said that
about 10 times by now.
Now the amazing
thing is that when
you come to the bipolar cells,
the next set of receptors here,
it was discovered
that two basic types
of several different types
like from for the major parasol
cells, but there are two basic
types, the on and the off.
And this is accomplished by
having two kinds of synapses
in the on and off bipolar cells,
sign conserving ones and sign
inverting ones.
This is accomplished
in the on bipolars
by virtue of the [INAUDIBLE]
six receptor site
and the [INAUDIBLE] one and
two for the off bipolar cells.
So that means now that you have
signals in some of these cells
when there's an increase in
light and the signals in some
where there's a
decrease in light.
So that's the situation for
the on and off bipolars.
And then when you come into the
level of the ganglion cells,
two major classes of ganglion
cells are the on and the off.
Now I'll talk about that in
more detail in just a minute.
Now the other
interesting, curious thing
is that when you
look at the rods,
the rods-- and they connect
to their bipolar cells.
They are all sign
inverting synapses.
They only come in one
type, at least in humans
and in primates.
So what happens then to
create on and off section
done in the inner
retina by virtue
of having a synapse here
[INAUDIBLE] to amacrine cell,
which is a glycinergic synapse,
and it also makes connections
to the on bipolar,
which is a gap junction.
And this way, it becomes
a double ended system
for the rods as well
as for the cones.
So hopefully you guys
all remember this.
I know it's complicated.
But that is something that one
doesn't have a choice about.
That's how it simply is.
All right, so now we move on.
And we are going to look at
the lateral geniculate nucleus.
Here's a cross section of it.
I've shown you before.
It was discovered that
the lateral geniculate
nucleus in central retina--
this is a monkey retina.
The human is very
similar, so input
from a monkey retina to the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
And the six layers consist
of two major types,
the parvocellular so called
the magnocellular layers.
And what was discovered is
that the parvocellular layers
get input from the
midget cells that we'll
talk about in just a minute.
And the bottom two layers, which
are the magnocellular layers
get input from
the parasol cells.
And then what happens is that
when you go from central vision
to peripheral vision,
you have a huge change
in the productive percentage
of midget and parasol cells
that you have in the retina
and in the lateral geniculate
nucleus near the fovea.
In the foveola itself, you
don't have any parasol cells,
but in the fovea itself you do.
And there's a ratio
of about eight to one.
And then as you go
to the periphery,
eventually they're
equally in number.
So there's a huge emphasis
on the midget system
in central vision and
the much increased
emphasis on the parasol
cells in peripheral vision.
So that's the arrangement.
And this is reflected
in the geniculate, which
has six layers in central
vision after about 18 degrees.
And it has four layers
in the periphery where
the midget and parasol
inputs are pretty much
equal as reflected
by these four layers.
So that's the basic arrangements
for the lateral geniculate
nucleus.
Now if we move on-- let
me say one more thing.
The receptive field properties
of cells in the retina,
in retinal ganglion
cells, I should say,
and in the lateral geniculate
nucleus are highly similar.
They're virtually identical.
You have circular
receptive fields
with centers around antagonism.
All right, now if you
move on and move up
to the visual
cortex, what happens
is that there's a huge
change that arises,
the beautiful discoveries
made by Hubel and Wiesel
for which they had
received the Nobel Prize.
And this is just a quick
view of the monkey brain.
Here is area V1.
I'll come back to the
other areas in a minute.
The nice thing about
this in the monkey
is that this area is
[INAUDIBLE] as I had told you.
And because of that,
it's easy to study
the cells and their
properties in area V1.
All right, so now if one
examines the properties
of single cells
in area V1, it was
discovered some major
transformations had occurred
in the inputs from the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
And these major transforms can
be summarized in just a second.
But I will first tell you
that there is a differential
input from the parvocellular
and magnocellular layers, which
project respectively to [? 4C ?]
beta and [? 4C ?] alpha.
And then there's
yet another class
of cells that originates in
the retina that are project
into the inter lamina
layers, and they
project into the upper
portions of the visual cortex.
So now if one looks in
detail at the properties
of these cells, which we
have discussed quite a bit.
You can refer to
these as transforms.
The transforms of the visual
input into the cortical cells.
So when you're record
from these cortical cells,
you'll find one big transform
is that these cells,
the overwhelming
majority of these cells,
become orientation selective.
Many cells become
direction selective,
virtually all simple cells and
about half the complex cells.
So direction selectively
becomes very important.
We'll talk about that in a
bit more detail later on.
Then, some cells are
spatial frequency selective.
Many cells get an
input from both eyes.
And there's a
convergence of input
from the on and off channels.
This is also true for
some of the cells that
get a convergent input from
the midget and parasol cells.
So those are the
major transforms
that you see in
the visual cortex.
All right, so now as a result of
having made these discoveries,
people came up with
a question of how
is this organized in
the visual cortex.
And the first point
that I had made
is that there's a
topographic layout
of the visual field
in visual cortex.
But with much more
area allocated
for central vision than
peripheral vision simply
copying the relative
percentage of cells
already in the retina that
exist in central vision
and peripheral vision
and because the thickness
of the gray matter in cortex is
about two millimeters roughly.
And it's constant.
More space has to be
allocated for central vision
than peripheral vision.
And as a result of
these people that
studied the spacial
arrangement and organization
of the visual cortex--
and the initial model
that was proposed,
if you remember,
is the Hubel and
Wiesel model, according
to which in one
direction you have
the alternation of
left and right eyes.
You have column, left,
right, left, right.
And in the other direction,
you have a systematic change
in the orientation of cells.
Now this model
didn't fare that well
because it's not as neat
as has been proposed.
An alternative model
was the Raidial model.
And the last one
I'm showing here,
which I call the Swirl
model is not really a model
because some very
clever experiments that
have been carried
out by [INAUDIBLE]
actually did optical
recording and demonstrated
that the visual
cortex from the top
looks something
like this where you
have indeed systematic
arrangement of orientations
in left and right eye columns.
But it's not a
straight linear factor,
but it's kind of a
swirly arrangement.
So that then established
what is the layout
of the primary visual cortex.
OK now the other important
thing that we had emphasized
is that contrary to some
of the popular ideas
that people have had that
the cells in the brain
are feature selective,
meaning that they'll extract
specific features from the
visual scene like say one cell
extracts color, another cell
extracts a particular face,
and so on.
It turns out that that's
a false impression
that people had gained.
And instead what is
happening that any given one
cell processes many different
kinds of visual information.
And it's the activity of
thousands and thousands
of cells in a network that
can come up with the percepts
that you perceive.
Now that's extremely
complicated, 10 times more
complicated than any computer.
And it is something
that to a larger extent
still has not been solved.
You don't know how does a
person recognize a face.
You can tell oh, it takes place
in various parts of the brain
and so on.
But exactly physically
how that's done
is something that's still
remains largely a mystery.
All right, so now
let's move on and talk
about extrastriate cortex.
And extrastriate cortex-- here's
a diagram of the monkey brain
again.
Now I'll point out
here's area V1.
And once you get close to
the lunate sulcus here,
V2 begins and folds under.
And then inside
there we have V3.
And then actually make
folds back out again.
You have area V4 here.
And then you have areas
MT and MST right here.
And then, in addition,
you have, of course,
your infertemporal
cortex area, which
plays a very important role in
complex analyses such as faces.
And then you come
to the frontal lobe
here, in which you have
the frontal eye fields
and medial eye fields that
also process visual information
but mostly for eye
movements that I
will talk about later on.
So that then is in a
nutshell the arrangement.
And much of the work that has
been done in the past dozen
years or so was to examine what
these extrastriate areas do
for vision.
And I'll come back
to that when we
talk about higher level
visual processing.
Now basically the
fact is that there
are more than 30 visual
areas and that there
are more than 300
interconnections among them.
Initially the idea was--
the feature detection idea--
that each of these areas
is specific for analyzing
a particular type of percept.
But then it became more evident,
increasingly more evident,
that these areas tremendously
interact with each other
and perform these
very complex analyses
based on networks being active.
Now the basic major
cortical visual areas,
V1 I just talked about, V2
I mentioned, V3, V4, MT.
Then when you come to
the temporal cortex,
you come to infertemporal
region that I just mentioned.
And then in the
parietal cortex, we
have the lateral
parietal sulcrus,
the ventral interparietal, and
the medial superior temporal
sulcrus.
So those are some
of the major areas.
And then as I've already
noted, in the frontal cortex,
we have the frontal eye fields.
And then even we had the medial
eye fields, which are not
listed here that
also play a role
in eye movements,
perhaps a lesser
extent in visual
analysis as such.
But many of the cells there too
have visual receptive fields,
although they are
very hard to discern.
They much more clearly have
motor fields than visual field.
All right so now what
we are going to do is
we are going to go
back to the beginning
and look at the so-called
on and off channels briefly.
We talked about that a lot.
Again, to reemphasize,
all photoreceptors
hyperpolarize to light.
And then because the two major
classes of neurotransmitter
receptor sites in
the bipolar cells,
you create a double ended
system from a single
ended one creating the
so-called on and off.
Now these systems were
discovered initially
by Keffer Hartline,
who received the Nobel
Prize for that
remarkable discovery.
And he thought at the
time that the on system
signaled when a
stimulus came on.
And the off channel
signaled when it went off.
That was his idea,
which turned out
to be all wrong because that's
not what these cells are about.
What these cells are about, as
I've pointed out repeatedly,
is that they can process both
light increment and light
decrement with an
excitatory response.
That means because of the
nature, the physical nature,
of light that some objects
in the world reflect light,
and some objects in
the world absorb light.
Because of this,
as you look around,
some objects look
black, and some objects
look white, or whatever.
And because of that, to
be able to rapidly process
something that is a dark object
as well as a light object,
you need to have
excitatory signals
to go to the central nervous
system to process that.
So therefore, we can
say, first of all,
that we have these cell types.
And they won't have sensor
surround antagonism.
And let me add
one more fact here
is that they're comfortable
with adaptation,
that the average firing rate,
average maximum firing rate,
of a retinal ganglion cell is
maybe about 400 to 600 hertz.
And that is a rather
limited frequency range.
And yet, you have to
analyze practically
over 10 log units of
light information.
And because of that, the
sensor surround antagonism
has evolved so that
these cells always
look at local contrast
changes rather than absolutes.
So then, if you look at
the on and off cells,
I've told you, in accordance
with the sensor surround
antagonism, if you split
a small spot of light
in the center of
receptive fields,
on cells fire when
you increase it.
Off cells fire when
you decrease it.
But when you use a
much larger spot,
you get a lesser
response because
of the surround antagonism.
So that's the basic principle
of these two types of cells.
And then, I told you
about these experiments,
in which two
2-amino-4-phosphonobutyrate had
been used, which is for
brief purposes, called APB.
And I told you about two
types of experiments,
one doing single cell recordings
in various parts of the brain
and the others to do
behavioral studies.
And what the signal cell
recordings had shown
is that the-- let me
first say what APB does.
APB is what?
Anybody remember?
It's a neurotransmitter analog.
And what neurotransmitter is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very good.
Glutamate.
All right so what you do is
when you inject this substance
into the eye-- this is
an artificial substance--
it blocks the on
cells from being
able to respond
to incoming light
but does nothing
to the off cells.
So if you do this and study
the responses of single neurons
in various parts of
the brain-- there
have been all these
different hypotheses
as to why we had the
on and off channels.
One of them was to create
sensor surround antagonism.
And the other one was to
create orientation direction
selectivism in the cortex.
But it turned out that when
you injected APB into the eye,
and you blocked the on channel,
the off input to the cells,
and the off cells
therefore, still
had sensor surround antagonism.
And the cells in
the cortex still
had orientation and
direction selectivities.
So these two systems
did not arise
for the purpose of creating
those basic attributes, which
are so central for being able
to analyze the visual scene.
Now the second
important finding was
that when you did
a behavioral study
and asked monkeys to
detect light increment
and detect light
decrement, there
was a huge deficit in detecting
light increments but no deficit
in detecting light decrement.
So these observations
and many other studies
analyzing why there
are on and off channels
came up with the
conclusion, which I think
is quite valid that
these two systems
have evolved to enable
organisms to quickly respond
to both light detrimental
and light incremental input.
And you probably remember
the little quick movie
I showed you that you
have a fish in the ocean.
Fish also have on and
off channels of course.
If there's a bird in the
sky, like an osprey that
is seen by virtue
of light decrement,
your off system tells
that fish, oh, there's
a bird up there
so it can escape.
And if a predator
from below that is
lit up by the sunshine, the
on system in response to that
and enables this fish to escape.
So that's one example of the
function, the prime function,
of the on and off channels.
All right so that's
the basic fact then.
So to conclude then,
the on and off channels
have emerged in the
course of evolution
to enable organisms to process
both light incremental and
light decremental information
rapidly and effectively.
So that's the conclusion
then in a nutshell
of the on and the off channels.
Now we can move on and look
at the so-called midget
and parasol cells that had
been discovered initially
in the cat.
And they were called
the x and y cells.
In the monkey, it's
called midget and parasol
because when you look
at them anatomically,
the midget cells are small.
And they're very
small dendritic arbors
where the parasols
cells are much bigger
and have much larger
dendritic arbors that
look like an umbrella.
So those two systems
were discovered,
and statistical analysis
revealed that they are totally
separate types of cells.
They're not a continuum.
So the question then became why
did these two systems evolve?
And why did nature
go to such trouble
as to make sure that they
were separate in retina
and separate in the
geniculate to the monkey?
And then, in the
cortex, sometimes it
remains separate-- sometimes the
two systems remain separate--
and sometimes they
converge as I had
noted in those
transforms in area V1.
So now if you look
at that, you've
seen this several times now.
The midget system, the
center in central retina
consists of just a single cone.
And therefore,
this system should
be able to tell you about color
whereas the parasol system has
mixed inputs both in the
center and the surround.
Furthermore, the parasol
system response much more
trangently than
the midget system.
So temporal information can
be processed more effectively
by the parasol system
than the midget system.
So those are the initial
observations at the single cell
level.
And then behavioral
studies were carried out
in which either the midget
or the parasol system
were selectively blocked.
And then performance was
tested where those systems had
been blocked and where
the systems were intact.
And when this was done,
some major findings emerged.
Before I tell you about
that, let me just reiterate
again what these
connections are.
Here we have the midget
and the parasol cells
as well as the cornea
cellular cells.
They project through
the geniculate
up to the visual cortex.
And then from there,
there has been
lots of debate as to what is
the nature of the connections
to higher areas in the brain.
And we talked about
that quite a bit.
And some beautiful
studies had been
carried out showing
that the input to area
MT in the parietal
lobe is dominated
by the parasol
system, but the input
to V4 in the temporal
lobe is about
equal for the two systems.
So that was the
basic factor then.
And so now the
question then comes up,
what is the contribution
of these two
systems, the midget
and the parasol?
And so experiments
are carried out
where lesions are made in either
parvocellular or magnocellular
geniculate.
And then the monkey was tested,
as I've said, in intact areas,
in areas where the midget
system and areas where
the parasol system
had been blocked.
Now one additional
fact is that when
you block both of
these by lesion
in the lateral geniculate
nucleus, for the most part,
the monkey becomes blind.
OK, so these two
systems are really
central for being able to
process visual information.
All right so now, if one looks
at what kinds of deficits
arise, a monkey can be
trained in a whole bunch
of different tasks.
It talked about these.
Color vision, texture
perception, pattern perception,
shape perception, brightness,
[INAUDIBLE] scotopic vision,
contrast sensitivity,
stereopsis, motion perception,
flicker perception.
We'll talk about those first.
So it was found that
there was severe deficits
after a parvocellular lesion,
meaning when the midget
system was blocked in color
vision, and texture perception,
pattern perception,
and shape perception.
Also in contrast sensitivity
and severe in stereopsis.
None of those cause a deficit
with the magnocellular region,
mean eliminating
the parasol system.
But when examine motion
perception and flicker
perception, there was a
moderate to major deficit
where that system was missing.
So that's then established.
I'll come back to these later.
Established at least
in some people's mind
why these two
systems have emerged
in the course of evolution.
And so a summary statement
to that effect is shown here.
If you look at the ability
to process spatial frequency
by the midget and
parasol system,
the midget system
can process it up
to much higher
spatial frequencies.
The obverse is the case when
it comes to temporal frequency.
The parasol system can
process to much higher levels
of rapid motion
or flicker, as you
can see in this little diagram.
So the midget system
extends the range
of vision in the spatial
frequency wavelength range.
And the parasol
system extends it
in the temporal frequency range.
So that's why these two
systems have evolved.
And then if you look
at this in terms
of the relative number of cells
in the retina that are devoted
to these two attributes--
I told you that
in the foveola, there no input
at all to the parasol system.
So therefore, what
about this fine vision
that the fovea makes possible
for you is due to the fact
that area is dominated
by the midget system.
Then as you go progressive
to the periphery,
that ratio changes as
I had just shown you
because increased
emphasis has to be placed
a seeing motion and rapid
changes in the periphery.
So that's what happens with
the parasol system's increased
number of cells in
the periphery that
can handle that requirement.
So now we're going
to move on and talk
about various aspects
of visual processing.
And we'll start first with
color vision and adaptation.
As I've shown you before, one
of the beautiful advances that
had been made initially
actually, believe it or not,
by Newton-- I mentioned
that I think--
was the discovery of-- I
shouldn't say discovery--
the invention on
the color circle.
Now this invention arose in part
because it was established--
it's a well-known
fact-- that we don't
have opposites along these axes.
You don't have a
yellowish blue color.
reddish green color.
But anything that's not an
opposite in this color circle,
you do have.
So you have yellowish red,
or you have yellowish green,
and so on.
So the color circle
was then elaborated
upon over many years.
This is a slightly
modified version
from what Newton had invented.
And this is set up
in such a fashion
that when you go
around this circle--
I should say disk I suppose--
you change the hue of course.
And then when you go from
the center of the periphery,
you increase saturation.
This is not the perfect
display, especially
because the projector
isn't perfect.
But the center is
supposed to be white.
And all this is
fairly equal luminent.
And so you go from
unsaturated to saturated.
Now I will say
already at this point
another very important
factor in appreciating
the beauty of the
color circle is
that when you
analyze after images,
it was found that if you adapt
to something that's yellow,
you adapt the eye
to this wavelength.
And then you shift
it to white, then
you get an after-effect,
which is blue.
And if you do that for red,
the after-effect is green.
And the same thing is all
the way around the circle.
If you have this one,
the after-effect is here.
So the color circle
perfectly predicts
what you're after images
are due to adaptation, which
occurs as a result of
having bleached selectively
the molecules in the various
cone types that we have,
the three cones,
red, green, and blue.
So that's the basic rule
of the color circle,
which can be used extensively.
And I think you
yourself can have
a lot of fun studying this
in your off time, which you
don't have too much of I'm sure.
But it's really a wonderful
thing to play around with.
Since this course is rather
heavily fact oriented,
I want you to remember
these basic facts
that I had listed before.
I just noted along
the color circle,
you have three attributes, hue,
brightness, and saturation.
And then I also mentioned
to you that there
is a distinction between
the psychological
and the physical
attribute of images.
And this arrangement is such
that I gave you an example of.
For example, when a tree
falls in the forest,
is there a sound when
there's nobody around?
And the answer is
a distinctive no.
Why?
Because sound is a
psychological attribute.
If you're on the
other hand, you'd
have said well, if a
tree falls in the forest,
through some
wavelength result that
are in the range of hearing.
And that, of course, yes.
But if you say sound,
that's something you hear.
It's not something
that's a physical thing.
So that applies to
many aspects of vision,
as well as audition
and many other senses
that you must make a
distinction between what
your psychological
disposition is as opposed
to what a physical fact is.
The next thing here
is that we have
three types of photoreceptors,
a short, medium,
and long wavelength
for the cones.
And then we have also
a different wavelengths
peak for the rods.
All of these peaks
are broadly tuned
to enable you to--
some are in the brain--
examine the relative
amounts of information
from these three wavelengths.
That then enables
you to perceive
many, many other colors partly
because of color [INAUDIBLE]
and partly because of variety
of amount of activity of them.
And then I mentioned
Grassman's laws.
Every color has a
complementary, which when mixed
properly yields gray.
That should do with again
with the color circle.
So in other words,
to go back to that,
if you mix yellow and
blue in equal amounts,
you get white or
gray I should say.
And the same thing for
anything that's and opposite.
But then if you mix
things which are not
at diagonals to each other, then
you get an in between color.
So if you mix yellow and
green, you get yellowish green.
All right so that's
Grassman's laws.
So if you have non complementary
colors, you get intermediate.
And if you get complementary
colors, you get gray.
Again to make sure that
you understand this,
complementary means this
and that, this and that,
this and that, which are on
the opposites on the lines that
intersect the center
of the color circle.
We move on.
And we talk about Abney's law.
That is not very important.
And you don't have
to remember that.
The luminance of a mixture
of differently colored lights
is equal to the sum of the
luminance of its components.
That another fact, but you
don't need to know that.
The last thing that
I want to mention
is so-called metamers, which
are stimuli which look the same
but are the product of different
subcompositions of wavelengths.
So because we only have three
different cone photoreceptors,
you can, in a
sense, if you will,
fool them a little bit by
very carefully mixing things
up with different wavelengths
to activate them equally.
So that is what is
called a metamer when
you can't tell the difference
between two stimuli.
They look identical even though
their wavelength compositions
are different.
OK so now another factor
that I should note here
when it comes to color
vision is that when
you look at the response
characteristics of cells
in the retina-- and I'm talking
about the retinal ganglion
cells-- when we look at the
cells in the geniculate, which
is here, what you find actually
is just a few major categories.
This is a color circle here.
And one presents the
stimuli around the circle
and see how the cell responds.
And what you're see
here is one cell,
which is a blue on cell, a green
off cell, a yellow on cell,
and a green on cell.
Now it turns out if you record
from hundreds and hundreds
of cells, you only
get these categories.
You don't ever get any cells
which are at the diagonals.
So to see the
diagonals, something
has to be taking place in the
cortex on the basis of what
is coming in from the retina and
the lateral geniculate nucleus.
Now when you come to adaptation,
we talk about that quite a bit.
And also with after images, I'll
come back to that in a minute.
It was discovered in
some very nice example
that you take a cell,
and you adapt it
to various levels of
overall illumination,
and then see how the
cell responds to it,
and then you stimulate
the receptive field.
What you find is that
here's the same cell.
Here's a background illumination
of a huge range over five log
units.
And what you find is that when
most of the cell is adapted,
it responds always the same.
So it's looking not at over
all levels of illumination,
it's looking at differences
in illumination.
It's looking at contrast.
Now how many of you remember
the formula for contrast?
Anybody?
All right, I think that's a
really good thing to remember.
I'm sure when you go
to a party, people
would be fascinated
by you knowing
the formula for contrast.
OK, so contrast
equals-- you take
the stimulus,
which is call it x.
And you take the background,
which you called y.
You subtract one from the other.
Then you add the two up.
And then you
multiply this by 100.
So that your contrast.
What this formula
means that this applies
to endless levels of
overall illumination.
You can do this in the sunshine.
You can do this in the
moonshine because you're
looking at the differences
between the background
and the stimulus itself.
AUDIENCE: What is x and y?
PROFESSOR: As I've said, x
is the illumination level
for the target.
Suppose you take a cell, and
you shine a spot of light on it
like that.
Then you remove it, and you
measure the background level.
And so x is a visual stimulus.
y is the background.
We talk about light adaptation.
Again, I want you to
know a few basic facts.
The overall level
of illumination
is close to 10 log units.
But in contrast to
that, if you just
look at reflected
light, that varies
over a much smaller
range because on the very
bright illumination
conditions, even a black object
will reflect some light.
So you're talking about direct
light versus reflected light.
So when you do reflected
light, you get a smaller range.
Now the pupil plays a role
in the amount of light
it controls getting
into the eye.
But it can only do that
over a range of 16 to one.
Now because of that, the
major role of adaptation
has to do with
the photoreceptors
in your rods and your cones.
And the way that works
is, if you remember,
is that you can think
of your molecules
in your photoreceptors as
existing in two forms, bleached
and unbleached.
And because of the
millions and millions
of them that I told
you already about,
1,000 times 10,000 in
just a single cone,
there's a relative percentage
of bleached and unbleached
molecules in each
cone and in each rod.
And so what is happening is
that during dark adaptation,
there's a huge increase
in the unbleached,
and during light
adaptation, there's
an increase in the
bleached molecules.
So therefore, any
increase in the rate
of at which quanta are
delivered to the eye
is also in the
proportion of decrease
in the number of
pigment molecules
available to absorb
those quanta.
Retina ganglion
cells are selected
sensitive to local
contrast differences
not absolute levels
of illumination.
I've said that many
times over again.
OK, and that's why this
formula, this contrast formula,
is one that's the most useful
in being able to depict
what kind of input
these cells are getting.
So that then is the arrangement
about light adaptation.
Now let's move on to depth
perception, which is one
the most intriguing capacities
that we have since our retinae
essentially are like a
two dimensional surface.
So whatever comes
onto the retina,
some mechanisms have
to be able to tell you
where things are in depth.
And because it's such
a complex problem,
quite a number of
different mechanisms
have evolved to make it
possible for you to do that.
And that means that first
we have oculomotor cues.
We don't need to
talk about those.
But we have visual cues,
which have binocular cues,
stereopsis we talked
about quite a bit.
And the binocular cues are
motion parallax, shading,
interposition size,
and perspective.
All these cues we can
utilize to tell us
where things are in depth.
So now if we look
at stereopsis--
I've handed out to you some
of these autostereograms.
If you look at these, you
can't see it looking at that.
You have to do it
on those sheets
that I handed out to you.
You can see something in depth.
And this arises by
virtue of the fact
that stimuli are arranged
in such a fashion
that they selectively activate
neurons in the visual cortex
that code depth by
virtue of the fact
that they get disparity
inputs from the two eyes.
Now another central
mechanism-- I
should add one more
thing about stereopsis.
I think I've mentioned it.
In fact, 10% of the population
in the United States lack
stereopsis in most cases due to
either misalignment of the two
eyes or do to ambliopia,
meaning one eye doesn't see
as well as the other.
But those people can
still do many things
and do depth quite well.
They can't thread
needles, but they
can do courser depth quite well.
And one of those is
due to motion parallax.
Now the basic rule
about motion parallax
that cause the brain
to evolve to analyze it
is that when objects
are different distances
from the eyes as depicted
here, the objects that
are closer to the
eye when this object
moves over a greater range
on the retinal surface
than those that
are further apart.
You can see the
green versus the red.
So therefore, the
system is such that it
has evolved to be able
to see small differences
in the relative motion of
objects in the retinal surface.
And I showed you
an example of that.
And I'll show it to you
again because this is fun.
This is essentially similar
to the random autostereogram
except it's just a single
bunch of random dots.
And as soon as I
set this in motion,
you see them in three dimensions
beautifully because these move
over a greater range than these.
And these move even less so.
So this differential
motion commands
you to see it in depth.
So that's quite a
remarkable ability.
And monkeys are even
better at it than we are.
And even fish have
this kind of capacity
as do many, many other species.
It's so central to our
ability to process depth.
OK
Studies have been
carried out to determine
where and how
these are analyzed.
And when we came
to where, here's
an example of looking at a
brain in a normal stereo-blind
subject.
When you only present
motion parallax,
you only presents stereo.
And when you do the
stereo, monocularly, you
don't see depth, and
the brain is not active.
So this tells you
which part of the brain
is active and involved
in analysis of stereopsis
and which one is involved in
the analysis of motion parallax.
I showed you this picture and
several others telling you
which areas it is.
The limitation of that
is that it can tell you
where it takes
place in the brain,
but it doesn't tell
you how it takes place.
So because of that,
many studies have
been carried out
doing single cell
recordings in these
cortical areas.
And it was discovered
that the there are indeed
cells already in
area 17 that get
disparate input
from the two eyes.
Beautiful work by
[INAUDIBLE] showing this.
And establish therefore
that already in area 17,
you have neurons that tell
you about stereoscopic depth.
And then it was also discovered,
especially in area MT,
to a lesser extent
already in V1 also,
that you have cells that
respond to differential motion.
And so those cells
are presumptively
involved in the processing
of depth information
based on motion parallax.
Now another mechanism
involved that we
talked about is shading.
Light coming from
above like from the sun
had been incorporated
into the visual system
to tell you whether an object
is towards you or away from you.
And this is an example of that.
Here the light is from above,
and the darkness is below.
This is reversed here.
And because of that, you
see this as protruding,
and you see this as receding.
And so I showed you several
examples, some in the handout,
of the fact that even shading
is a hue that's used quite
extensively in depth perception.
Now we come to form perception.
I'll talk about this briefly.
I mentioned three
kinds of theories.
One is that the former
is due to the fact
that neurons respond
selectively to line
segments of different
orientations in V1.
Another theory was that
they have a spatial mapping
of the stimuli on to the
visual cortex since you
have topography.
And the third one is
that form perceptions
are accomplished by
Fourier analysis.
We talked about each of these.
And I pointed out to
you that even when
there are no orientation
segments in the display,
you can still see and
identify faces quite well,
as seen in the Wall
Street Journal where
these kinds of pictures appear
every day in the paper itself.
Now then if you move
on, and you look
at the layout of how the
cortexes-- this is a monkey
cortex here.
This is a visual field.
If you present these three
stimuli in the visual field,
this is the area that's
activated in the cortex
because more area is
allocated to central vision
and peripheral vision.
And so you say oh, this
is much bigger than those.
But that's not the case.
You can tell that
they're identical.
Now even more
dramatic is the fact
that if you put these three
disks centered-- OK, so half
of it goes to the
ipsilater and half of it
to the contralateral
visual hemisphere.
What you get are a bunch
of half circles like that.
And it doesn't look
anything like that.
So the idea that somehow
images are laid down
in the visual cortex, and
the mind then looks at it
is totally wrong.
It's wrong to the extent
that it's ridiculous.
The last analysis theory
is accepted by some people.
And doing computer analyses has
revealed that system actually
can be mimicked
extremely well based
on what we know about
the organization
of the visual cortex.
It has all the basic
attributes that you need,
orientation,
direction selectivity,
and phase that enable
you to break down
the visual scene in an
analytical fashion, which
is kind of foreign to our
thinking, namely Fourier
analysis.
Then we spent some time talking
about prosthesis, which you're
going to hear quite
a bit about actually
when Chris Brown is going to
lecture because that has been
so successful in
the auditory system
with the cochlear implant, which
is a remarkable achievement.
We have many more
than 50,000 by now
in the United States who
have cochlear implants.
And they can talk and do all
kinds of remarkable things.
We don't have this
in the visual system.
And I've mentioned to you that
one of the big differences
is that in the retina, there
are more than a million fibers
in each eye that come from the
ganglion cells that project
into the brain, whereas when you
talk about the auditory system,
you only have about
30,000 fibers.
So the magnitude is much less.
But also there
are other factors,
namely the retina is a
very difficult structure
to work with.
And also when people become
blind, most cases the retina
degenerates.
So you can't put a
device into the eye
very effectively in most
blind people to create vision.
So another alternative is
to try some other regions.
Some people have advocated to
do this in the visual cortex.
And the problem there is we have
the huge magnification factor.
So if you put 256 stimuli
like this in the visual scene,
this is the actual
physical activation.
And once you know
what this layout is,
then you can put electrodes
in, which are spaced like this.
Then, if you were
to stimulate these,
then you would create an image,
which is at least moderately
similar to this that would
be in slightly different
washed out colors, but which
would still essentially
be a square.
So if you do that then,
and you take a camera,
and you take the
input to the camera
and connect it selectively
to this proportional implant.
If you put the word, fiat
lux-- remember what that is?
Let there be light.
You get a pretty
good reproduction
of what has been put in there.
But by contrast, if you take
a ray of electrodes, which
are equally spaced-- then,
if you activated all those,
you would get a butterfly image.
And if you then put in the
fiat lux to the camera,
it would look like that.
So that would mean
that they would
get a pretty false
impression of the world,
and you wouldn't be
able to even read.
So therefore, it would be very
important to take into account
the functioning of
the visual system,
as well as functioning
of the individual neurons
if you are going to create
a prosthetic device.
So now we will move on.
And I will say a few
words about illusions.
We talked about quite
a few illusions,
and you got some of
those in the hand out.
The one I mentioned to you
that I think all of you enjoyed
is the Hermann grid
illusion, which
shows the smudges at the
smudges at the intersections.
And the famous theory that
was advanced by Baumgartner
is that it's due to the fact
that if you have a cell that
is centered around
here, as opposed
to not at the intersections,
this cell would
be inhibited more than this one.
So this hypothesis had been
accepted by many people
a few years back,
and it has appeared
in many, many textbooks.
It turns out this
theory is all wrong
if you remember
because first of all,
here you just make
a small change
in the physical
layout of the lines.
And you don't get
the effect at all,
even though if you put a cell
here, as opposed to here,
the arrangement
is still the same.
So consequently,
that theory is wrong.
And it's even further proven by
the fact that when you analyze
it physically to see what the
number of cells is in this area
here-- and this is
for parasol cells.
And this is for
the midget cells.
You have a huge number of cells.
And this is shown
only for the on cells.
You can double that
for the off cells.
You would activate
this teeny area here,
five degrees from the fixation.
You would activate 365 midget
cells and 50 parasol cells,
half of which would be on and
half of which would be off.
So this theory is
just incorrect.
And so alternative ideas
have been developed still
sort of under debate.
And one is that this takes place
because of the simple cells
in the visual cortex as
we have talked about it.
Now then, another set of
illusions we talked about
are the after-effect illusions.
And the experiments that
we so informally did here
asked if you look at
a particular display,
you fix it for a while, and
then you change the display,
you have an after-effect, right?
A very dramatic after-effect.
And one of those was the
rotating dots in the circle.
And I showed it to you.
The experiment was that you
adapt to it with one eye,
and then you look at the display
afterwards with the other eye,
and then you would
have no effect, which
proves that this takes
place in the retina
and proves it is due
to the adaptation that
takes place in the
photoreceptors.
All right so those were
the so-called interlocking
experiments we had discussed.
So now let me move
on and talk some more
about the deficits in vision
arise as a function of lesions.
And I already showed
you a whole set
of those when we talked
about the lesions
of the midget and
parasol systems.
And now if you look at
this in more detail,
we add to this,
what happens when
you remove V4 and remove MT?
And it's quite striking
that the deficits are far,
far less when you take
out the midget system.
You have very mild
deficits with V4 lesions
for most of these up here.
These are basic
visual capacities.
But MT lesions do give you
pretty much the same deficits
as a magnocellular lesion that
blocks the parasol system.
Now then when
higher level visual
capacities we have now
analyzed-- I showed you those
as well-- you found
that there was
some dramatic deficits with
V4 lesions when monkeys
had to choose less a stimuli and
had to learn visual percepts,
they had severe deficits
with a V4 lesion.
So that suggests
that an area like V4
plays a very important role in
higher level visual processing.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What does
the pronounced mean?
Is that--
PROFESSOR: Pronounced?
It means like a strong deficit.
AUDIENCE: So more than severe?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
You can see by the color also.
Severe is the strongest.
Pronounced is strong.
Moderate is weaker.
And mild is mild. [CHUCKLES]
OK so now, next I want to
turn to eye movement control.
And when we do that
I want to remind you
that the many cortical areas as
well as the subcortical areas
that play a significant role
in eye movement control.
And one way to test this is
to electrically stimulate
various regions in
the brain and see
if you get any eye movements.
And this happens in many areas.
The ones we have here are
superior colliculus, of course,
we talked a lot about.
V1, LIP, the medial eye fields,
and the frontal eye fields.
Now in all but one
of these you get
a constant vector [INAUDIBLE] at
any sight where you stimulate,
meaning no matter where the eye
is looking when you stimulate,
you've got a particular
vector as depicted here.
The exception to that
is the medial eye fields
where you have a place code.
The result of stimulating
any given area
is to bring the eye,
normally where the eye is,
into that motor field.
Now different regions
obviously in these areas
have different vectors.
So that's the basic layout.
And then the question arose how
do these get down to the brain
stem ocularmotor complex that
drives the eye muscles that we
had talked about.
Well, the way the
experiment was done then
is to remove the
superior colliculus.
And when that was
done, what you found
was really quite
dramatic, namely
that you could no
longer drive cells
from the posterior
part of the cortex,
but you could still drive
them from the anterior part.
This led to the idea that
you have two major systems
in saccadic eye
movement generation,
the so-called posterior system
and the anterior system.
And then when people looked
at the question of well,
we have these two systems.
What do they do?
It was discovered that
the posterior system
is very important for generating
quick saccades, especially
express saccades, because when
you remove the colliculus,
you never got an
express saccade again.
And the anterior system plays a
very important role in stimulus
selection and the
sequencing of eye movements
because you make so many eye
movements in rapid succession,
you have to make
plans ahead to decide
where you're going to
look in a sequence.
And that was found to be very
important for the frontal eye
fields because when
you remove that, there
was a major deficit in target
selection and in sequencing.
So then when this
was done, we also
examined, if you remember
the question, of what
is the role of these various
areas when you block inhibition
or you increase inhibition.
So we use muscimal
and bicuculline to do
that as shown here.
And it showed that with V1,
you get a strong interference
with both, and you also
get a strong deficit
in visual discrimination
because to be
able to analyze
the visual scene,
you need to have interaction
between excitation
and inhibition both
for eye movements
and for visual discrimination.
And then with a frontal
eye field lesion,
you've got facilitation as
you did in the colliculus
when you put in bicuculline,
which eliminates inhibition.
The monkey couldn't
help but makes saccades.
But you've got
interference with muscimal.
LIP had no effect.
So that's then in a summary
was what we had discussed.
And this is
something, of course,
you need to go over
again in your notes,
and in Stellar, and in
the assigned readings
so that you can remember
this for the exam.
OK and then I pointed out to
you that even though we never
think of eye movements, we
have an incredible number
of structures and
a number of tasks
to be able to make
each eye movement.
We have to select a target.
We have to decide what each--
every time you move your eye,
there are dozens of targets.
We have to select one of those.
Then we have to
decide what they are.
Then we have to decide
which one to look
at which one not to look at.
And then we have to
use our system, which
is a spatial organization
of the motor fields
to eventually generate
an eye movement.
Now in reality then what happens
is that many other systems--
I showed you this before, too--
many other systems are involved
in generational eye movements,
hearing, touch, so on.
And we had generated
all sorts of systems
to enable for you to do this.
the so-called anterior
and the posterior systems
that reach the brain stem
through various channels here.
This is available for
you on the internet.
It's also available to you
on the assigned reading.
So now lastly we'll turn
to motion perception.
And when we talked
about motion perception,
I pointed out to you
that in the area of V1,
we have simple cells,
and complex cells,
several different
classes of simple cells.
And almost all of these cells,
if you look at their responses
to light increment
and light decrement,
meaning light edges
and dark edges,
almost every one of these
cells is direction selective.
And it's also true for
most complex cells.
About half the complex
cells, maybe more,
are also direction selective.
So direction selectivity is one
of the most central features
in the visual system
that we use extensively
not just to analyze
motion but also
to be able to see depth
by virtue of motion.
Paradox
So now we can say, because of
all those little experiments
I had shown you, that the
parasol system and because
of the lesion experiments
plays a central role in motion
analysis.
And when we do those experiments
with a apparent motion, when
we moved little spots in
color or in small differences
in shape, color and
small difference in shape
didn't matter, indicating
that the parasol system plays
a central role in us seeing
apparent motion the way we
see it.
All right.
So now, last very briefly
I want to say here
is about the
accessory optic system
because this is what you're
going to be writing about.
And I just wanted to remind you
that the basic discovery was
that in the retina, the
cells of [INAUDIBLE] that
feed into the accessory
optic system come in three
different direction
selectivities as shown here
and that these three direction
selectivities correspond
to the direction selectivity
of semicircular canals.
That's quite a
remarkable discovery.
And this then
enables the organism
through the system,
which by the way
these cells respond to all
the slow movements, that's
prime function is
to-- so they claim,
and I think that's
correct-- is to stabilize
the eye with respect
to the world.
So when you walk
around, what happens
is you can still see the world
very clearly with no blurring
because the accessory optic
system adjusts the eye
to keep it stable with respect
to the world out there.
And in fact, I can't remember
if I told you this story.
Way back when in Germany
when some people were treated
for pneumonia, they used the
drug-- I forget the name of it
right now-- that
caused malfunctioning
in the semicircular canals.
As a result of
that, that system,
which co-exists with the
accessory optic system
no longer was able to
stabilize the eyes.
And so here was this guy in
Munich living in a neighborhood
where he had lived
for many, many years.
And he realized that he
can't see anything clearly
when he's walking on the street.
Everything was blurry.
And so he said oh, my god.
I won't be able to
recognize my friend.
say hello to him.
And so what he
learned to do is this.
Hi, Joe.
Like that.
He stabilized his
head by holding it.
So that highlights
for you the fact
that this system of
stabilizing the eye
through the accessory
optic system
plays a very
important central role
in your being able to
move around in the world
and being able to analyze
the visual scene in spite
of the fact that
you're moving around.
So the last thing I wanted
to show you-- first,
I'm going to show
you one more picture.
But first, let me say a couple
of words about the exam again.
I've told you the exam is
a multiple choice exam,
probably something about
100 or so questions.
Almost all of them
deal with basic facts,
I should say basic facts.
So you've got to
know your facts.
And what you need to do
is read each question,
circle the choice.
You don't get punished
extra for being wrong.
If you're wrong, you're wrong.
But I'm not going
to subtract on top
of that the wrong answers
from the right answers.
So choose an answer,
even if you don't know it
for every question.
And you'll have a probability of
one in four, maybe one in five
of getting the right answer
if you're totally ignorant.
So that's what the exam is.
It's going to take about an
hour or so, hour and a half
maybe, depending on
how fast you read
and how fast you make decisions.
And that's going to take
place this coming Wednesday
right in this room.
Now the last thing I
wanted to show you is-- I
mean I seem to be so
certain about everything
being right and wrong here.
I just wanted to tell you
one thing, a note of caution.
And the caution
is this one here.
This is a wonderful
sculpture by Naum Gabo.
I don't know if you've
ever heard of Naum Gabo.
Anyway, this is obviously
you can almost instantly
say it's an upper body
and a face, right?
But the fact is
that, as I say here,
as many scientific
hypotheses of brain function
are appealing but a far
cry from the real McCoy.
So we are still groping.
And yes, we are a long
way from phrenology,
but still many of the hypotheses
and ideas that we have
are wrong and are more like
a cartoon of what it really
is like.
And of course, the
further up, in my opinion,
you go from the
retina, the higher
the fancifulness of the ideas.
At least when it
comes to the retina,
I think we are
reasonably comfortable
that we know a lot
about the photoreceptors
and how they interact.
And that's fairly close
to the way it really is.
So that may be more like
a photograph of Obama.
But when it comes to the
cortex of the higher areas,
things are a bit more like that.
So that's the end of it then.
Thank you very much.
And I wish you the best of
luck on your exam on Wednesday.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
That's very nice.
I appreciate it.